Do you know what consultants actually do?
How the life of a
consultant at an MBB firm
like McKinsey, BCG, or
Bain actually looks like.
In today's video, we're going to take
an alternative view at this topic.
We will analyze the live of a consultant
by reviewing memes from a
big consulting meme channel.
So the purpose of this is
not only that we are going
to have some fun together
but I will also explain
to you whether the memes
are actually accurate.
I will provide some insights
into the insider jokes
that are sometimes present in these memes.
So I trust that by looking at this video,
not only are going to have some fun
but you will also learn something new.
So stick with me until the very end
because I really believe
that every single meme
has a little lesson to it,
a little inside to it
that I hope to bring over.
Welcome to another coffee break
here on my channel Firm Learning.
My name is Hilliken.
On my channel I want to help
you to become successful
in the first y ears of your career.
If you are a regular watcher
of this channel, welcome back.
And if you're new on this channel,
I want to pass on some of my experiences.
Having been a consultant
at Accenture and McKinsey
now working in a C level
role of a German Retailer.
On this channel, I give career advice,
I talk about consulting and management
and I help you with some
technical kills and Excel
and PowerPoint that you need
to succeed in a business job.
But now without further
ado, let's jump into it.
So for the memes, we're
looking at the Instagram page
of Crazy Management Consultants,
for there are many consultant
meme channels out there.
Crazy Management Consultants
is probably my personal favorite.
If you're interested in this
type of content, check it out.
I can very much recommend it
and I will leave a link to
the Instagram account below
in the video description.
And of course the credits
for all these memes
go too Crazy Management Consultants,
so thank you very much for this.
Now I already preselected
a couple of the memes
that I wanna talk about
with you guys today.
So let's just start.
So here's now a comparison
of types of headaches,
migraine, hypertension,
stress, and staffed on DD.
And obviously here the DD seems
to stress you out the most
and create most headaches, right?
But what is the DD and why
is it so stressful work?
So a DD stands for due diligence.
So what this means is that
if somebody wants to buy
a company, you need to do
the due diligence, right?
You need to check the company,
you need to look into it,
look into all the books and so on.
And the reason why DD's are so stressful
are for two reasons.
So first they're often in a
very short amount of time.
So typically DD goes on for
two or three or four weeks.
There are some lots of things
that need to be accomplished
in the short amount of time.
And then second, the clients you work for
are you really super professional
and also used to work a lot.
So if you get staffed on a
DD, yes you might learn a lot,
it might still be very interesting
but be aware that in terms of lifestyle
it can be one of the most horrible things
that happen to you.
Okay next.
So every consultant I'm getting
out here by end of the year
and then same consultant
and seven years later.
Why am I still here?
That indeed very frequently
people, in the beginning say,
"Oh, I'm just going to stay
one or two or three years
and then I'm going to leave."
But then many people indeed
end up staying for much longer.
And the reason there
probably is that of course
the consulting firms
make it quite comfortable
for you, right?
The salaries and of course also
all the additional benefits
that you have while you work
in such an MBB consulting firm.
These are of course great.
And of course you always have also
the next designation
window in front of you.
So it's always very tempting for you
to just stay one more year.
Okay next.
And here we now have a little clip.
So watch carefully.
See, I mean, here the joke of course is
that the more senior, really
the older guys like partners,
I mean yes, they might know
what have you look up is
and they are great.
But of course the guys who are
really strong and et cetera.
These are the juniors, right?
These are the business
analysts, maybe the associates
who really are pretty much spending 50%
of their whole time working in Excel.
And of course, this is really amazing.
The level of proficiency that you get.
If you work for one or two
years into it's like Excel,
this would be far superior than
let's say 98% of all employees
even managerial accountants
in large corporate firms.
So this is for sure
something that we will learn.
And it is a skill that might
be quite significantly valued
in other companies as well.
Okay guys, next one.
Someone, "I have a PhD in physics."
Me, "I have a PTSD in consulting."
So of course not take
this with a grain of salt.
Now by no way, I wanna be little people
who really have PTSD.
So I by no means believe that, you know,
the stress of consulting
leads you into this.
The truth is of course
that working in consulting
can be quite stressful.
And I do think that actually
there are some people
who have some type of
traumatic experiences also
after they spent several years there.
And in the end it's all about
how you deal with stress and anxiety.
And if this is a topic
that you are interested in,
I made a video about
that actually last week.
So we'll link it somewhere above here,
check it out if you want
to learn more about this.
That okay next.
Let's move to another topic.
So people who use pie
charts, first of all clients,
high school students,
other non consultants
and virtual interns about to get fired.
And indeed here, the fun thing is that
consultants almost never use pie charts.
I mean, this is just the truth
because it's just not a great
way to visualize your data
in most instances.
And if you want to learn more about that,
I made a whole video course
about how you can create
PowerPoint presentations
in the style of leading consulting firms.
So if this is something
you're interested in,
check out the link below
in the video description.
It's my best selling course.
I trust you can learn a
lot of things from there.
So check it out if you're interested.
Next, Bezos, "Hey, need
those Q2 earnings slides
but please don't waste
more than an hour on them.
5th Grader who just
learned PowerPoint. Okay."
Now here you see these slides
which apparently indeed
are from an actual
conference call from Amazon.
So now I do not know
whether this is really true
but I guess it is, right?
And in a detail, if you
look at these slides,
they just look completely unprofessional.
And again if you wonder
and if you don't see
why it's unprofessional
then let me hit you again to this course
that I was just talking about.
And here of course what you
unfortunately see quite often
that even these very
large firms like Amazon,
they somehow don't really
seem to have employees
who are good in working with PowerPoint.
Next, and this is actually meme
that I've seen quite
frequently in the last week.
So this is how that
meme went pretty viral.
So what this shows is an actual
or maybe also fake LinkedIn profile
of a consultant who says then, okay,
"What it was in my role across
in all these different roles
that I had at the firm?
And here as an associate,
my role was to make pretty slides fast
as an engagement manager.
So as a project lead it
was more make other people
make pretty slides fast.
And then as an associate partner,
it was about convincing
clients pretty slides
will lead to real impact."
And of course, this is now, you know,
making a bit fun of this
cliche of consultants
that all they do is
creating pretty slides.
And unfortunately it is
the truth that of course
in consulting, as everywhere
projects can also fail.
And then indeed the only thing
that's left is pretty slides.
But of course from my experience,
this is a bit too simplistic.
There are many projects
that I worked on, that yes,
that really delivered great impact,
where I believe not only us as consultants
but also the clients were super satisfied
and happy with the results.
And that we believe it
was just completely unfair
to say that the only
thing that was created
in the end were slides.
Now next one.
Partner comments at 2am be like,
please turn into charting
and then a weird scribble.
And guys, this really happens, right?
So this is really kind of
from an associate perspective,
the cliche that, you
know, a partner walks in,
you know, maybe also your project lead,
he makes a weird scribble
over page and then he sends it
to you and then he wants you
to create a page out of that.
And then you look at it and
in the case of the partner,
you know, maybe then
you ask the whole team
to look at this and try to
come up with what this actually
was supposed to mean.
And then often, you
know, it's really hard.
So, you know, this is
just what it is guys.
This is indeed what your life
as a consultant will look like.
Next, when there's a fire in your office
but you are also consultant.
So there's a fire alarm and
then the consultants walk out
with their laptops and then
still try to work outside.
And frankly, this happens, right?
(laughs)
And this happens not only
rarely because on every project
because usually it's
part of the drill routine
that every couple of months
there's a mock fire alarm.
And then of course as a consultant
you are exposed to that as well.
And you know, there is here say of teams
that there may be, you know,
still state in the building
but this of course would
be against all protocols
and you will get usually into trouble.
So of course as a consultant
you are supposed to leave
the building if there
is a fire alarm guys.
(laughs)
So for sure you should leave the building.
And maybe you have a project
lead who is a bit unexperienced
and suggests that you should stay
because you have work to do.
No guys, stand up and tell him to leave
because we're gonna get into huge trouble,
I mean, I've heard crazy
stories about this.
But then of course
unfortunately, you know,
as a consultant you're
working on tight timelines,
you cannot wait for hours standing outside
of the building and waiting until
this mock fire alarm goes off.
So indeed what happens is that
often you would take a laptop
and then you would go outside
and then you will indeed sit somewhere
outside to try to get your work done.
But of course also here be careful
because then it's best if
it's possible to not do it
in front of the whole
company of the client,
because of it make you
look a bit ridiculous.
So always try to manage the
impressions here a little bit.
Okay, next one.
I have a consulting joke
but it's hard to execute it.
So yeah, this is just, you know,
making fun a bit of consultants
because consultants apparently
are bad at execution.
They can talk a lot,
they can draw nice strategy presentations.
Probably everything that
they say is somehow correct.
but then they underestimate
how difficult it can be
really to execute the things.
And frankly, and I necessarily
would not have I thought
that when I was working in consulting
but now reflecting on
my time in consulting,
I would say that this is
true, this is accurate.
And again I also made a video about that,
about the things that you
do not learn in consulting.
I will also link it somewhere above here,
but this is accurate and
if you wanna learn more
about this, check out this
video that I linked above.
Okay, next one, what my PowerPoint
deck is made off, right?
So what is it made of?
And a big part copied from existing deck.
So for sure, you will always recycle pages
from maybe other presentations
that you did maybe a week
ago that are a bit similar
and then you can recycle some pages.
Then for sure there are some
partner whiteboards scribbles
in there.
So we talked about these
crazy scribbles that partners
might make on a whiteboard
or a piece of paper.
And then you will try to
translate that into a chart.
Info from Google and Wikipedia.
So here, I would say, not that much.
So we, personally we don't
really use data from Wikipedia
because then you also need to put a source
next to the data, right?
And then you cannot just quote Wikipedia.
So this is unprofessional.
So this isn't really what I've seen.
Then next, client data nicely formatted,
into what I would say actually the share
is much larger, right?
So very frequently you
will get client data
and then of course it might
do some analysis with it.
But I would say a big part
of your whole presentation
is often at least of course depends
on the project context is analyzing
or process data form a clients.
Quotes from experts.
So those for sure.
So you will half more quantitative pages
which pretty much draw from the interviews
that you have with experts either external
or internal experts that have
again you get some knowledge from.
Highly illustrative analysis.
So this is something you know,
very rough that you put in there for sure.
This happens.
So them partner deleting pages
they previously has to asked to add.
(laughs)
So yes, this happens a
lot, this for sure happens.
So this is just the truth I can tell you.
Then indeed one next, steps page.
So this is also the cliche that in the end
you always have one page and at the end
of your presentation,
talking about next steps,
then yes a huge appendix
is a pretty much slides
that for whatever reason to create it
throughout the whole process.
But in the very end, then
you decide to just put it
to the appendix and then
just adds up to 420.
So guys with the
qualifications that are set,
actually I believe probably, you know,
the shares are roughly accurate.
I would say in all that the average deck
has less than 420 pages, right?
In all fairness, you
know, a big steer co deck,
the big one probably
has a 100 to 250 pages.
So I just, if you're asking
yourself what types of pages
you will have in your consulting deck,
yes this is accurate,
this is what you will need to do guys.
I hope that this was indeed insightful.
If you have any questions,
leave me a comment below.
And if you leave a comment,
not only will you get my answer
I will provide my best
insight to the question
that you might have but
you are also helping me
out a lot because every
comment helps me tremendously
with the YouTube algorithm.
So if you did take any value
out of this video at all,
please hit the like button
for the YouTube algorithm
and also subscribe to my channel,
to stay up to date on all of my content.
If you want to see even more from me,
also follow me on my Instagram account.
My handle is @firmlearning
and also have a mailing list.
There's a signup link to that
in the video description below.
I now wanna say thank
you to all the members
of Firm Learning, your contribution
really means a lot to me.
So if you want to help me and
support my channel as well,
there's a join button next
to the subscribe button
where you can become a member.
And as a member, not only
are you supporting my work
but you have also access
to some member only perks.
So check it out of this as something
that you might be interested in.
As you know, I'm releasing a new video
every single Saturday.
So I'm very much looking
forward to see you again
in one week and until then,
good weekend to all of you guys.
Bye bye.